foreign
Crowder
this 27 first half points by the Suns
and the booze cascading down a new
season low and points and a half for the
Suns the number one team in the NBA the
only 60 win season but the fact that
they're going so hard to the rim is
forcing all of this foul shooting and
you got to give Denver a ton of credit
they are shooting a great
percentage at the foul line you know
there are a lot of people locally that
said oh the sun's without the under
eight and that they're fine they're
better without Chris Paul they play
better without Chris Paul I guess guess
what yeah they miss both guys terribly
in this first half yes they do Denver
puts up 81 points they have their
largest halftime lead in franchise
playoff history
Suns fans are booing as their team
Trails by 30.
and halftime